Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David,
yesterday I spoke about Jamie Raskin, the
Democratic congressman, as a potential Democratic
presidential candidate. Were Joe Biden not to
run? Many of you liked it, but many of you agree.
The fact that Raskin is Jewish will make it an
uphill battle for him, many of you acknowledging
that here is the egg man agreeing with that.
Speaker 4: Hey, Dave, I really love Jamie Raskin,
too. He's a total mensch. That's why
he's not going to ever be nominated for
president. He can never win. He's somebody
sketchy and somebody with more skeletons
in their closet. Nobody like him. Somebody
less Jewish. They say that shallow brother.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. No, I mean, I think it's
it's very clear that in the current environment,
Raskin would have to deal with a lot of
anti-Jewish sentiment if he were to run. But there
is. I mean, I know Eichmann's being funny. Raskin
seems so clean, like maybe he does have skeletons
in his closet and I don't know about them,
but you tend to need someone with a history of
like off color remarks, which become the source of
controversy or family drama or whatever. I mean,
Raskin story is just sad. I mean, one of his one
of his kids died, actually died, died by suicide.
But it doesn't seem to have the types of skeletons
in his closet that seem almost ubiquitous
in in American politics. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. The Texas attorney general is
now suing over the Biden airport and airplane mask
mandate. Could this be the next thing to fall? A
woman has been cured of HIV thanks to a stem cell
transplant, and the Justice Department is suing
Missouri over a new gun law. We'll talk about all
of those stories on today's bonus show. Sign up
it. Join Pacman dot com to get instant access.
Unidentified: I will see you that.